good morning John about a week ago I saw
this comic from Korean artists Yahoo on
tumblr it had 88,000 notes this is I
feel a common and persistent theme that
I'm hearing from people on the Internet
I heard it from people who came to my
shows and talked to me I hear it from
people in my real life and in my own
brain I hear this the thing that we want
and we crave in our lives in addition to
stability is meaning and I think it's
getting harder and harder to find a
whisper of culture tells us that salary
is a good surrogate for Mina but we're
also asked and we want to make a change
to help people to make the world a
better place you want to have an impact
a big one like what's-his-face from
Facebook or Elon Musk I honestly can't
remember his name right now what is it
Zuckerberg and while you're at it might
as well fulfill all of the hashtag goals
you got to have your squad goals and
your relationship goals and your career
goals in your kitchen goals and if you
don't have it all then you're not quite
there so keep working and keep wanting
and someday maybe culture has always
told us lots of lies but it seems like
it's getting better at it look back at
that comic what signal are we getting
from culture that individual humans
matter at all when human labor is
commoditized as it is now when do we
stop appreciating the work that people
do to make our lives better and when
that happens when do we stop ever
feeling appreciated for the work that we
do without humans appreciating humans
for the work they do where is meaning
supposed to come earlier this week I
asked Twitter if they would rather be
happy or make a difference now in
addition to it being almost exactly a
50/50 split a ton of people said they
could not imagine being happy without
making a difference problem is our
cultural mythology is the thing that
tells us what counts as making a
difference and the most common
surrogates for that are Fame and money
and those metrics suck they have to suck
because they will always be scarce and
they will always be defined in relation
to what other people have not in
absolute terms we're headed into a world
that is dramatically different from the
one that our parents lived in a world
where many machines are going to take
over the jobs that humans have had and
as fewer and fewer people have what we
would consider normal employment normal
jobs we're gonna have to redefine not
just what work is but what meaning is
because we all want to make a difference
and it makes sense that we all want to
make a difference because we are a
cultural species that drive is what has
made humanity so wonderful and powerful
but I think we're starting to expect a
little too much in this rig
we can't all be Elon Musk in fact I
would argue that Elon Musk can't be what
we think of as Elon Musk Thomas Edison
didn't invent the light bulb the Wright
brothers didn't invent flight Elon Musk
has never built an electric cause these
are all stories they're good stories
they're inspiring stories but they're
stories we tell because the real story
is too complicated that's the story of
how every human being that has existed
and currently exists labored together to
build this world and yeah humans will
always have arguments about the best way
to do that and some of the ideas we've
had have been claw Sulli bad but in our
tour van last week George George said
something to me that I will never let go
of tonight we feast on the labor of
centuries because we do every day and
every night the good things that we have
in our lives are mostly because other
people worked to make life better and
all I can ask is that my forgotten
Labor's will add to the forgotten labors
of other people that have made life on
Earth better and as I've worked harder
to try and appreciate all of the work
that has gone into building my home in
my town and my country and my world I
find myself being happier with Who I am
and where I am coz in the end we matter
because we make life better for people
around us and also for people in the
future the story of humanity is not a
story of a few people who had huge
gigantic effects on the world that's
only the story we hear because it's the
easy story to tell caring for ourselves
and other people is the only thing that
has ever mattered to the future of our
species and sometimes even that care is
very difficult but other times it won't
be in that even when I've had really
dark times in my life is the one thing
that I've tried to be sure about John
I'll see you on Wednesday